here are three big takeaways from last
night's primary elections in New
Hampshire number one the Romney bubble
gets more hot air the headlines from
last night and understandably so with
that Mitt Romney becomes the first non
incumbent president to win both Iowa and
New Hampshire and New Hampshire by a
comfortable margin he seems to be on a
glide path to the nomination and yet
exit polls show that the single largest
block of support for any candidate were
the sixty-two percent that wanted to
vote for Romney because he was the most
electable he is the biggest chance of
beating Barack Obama the moment Mitt
Romney does not appear electable is the
moment that he gets in trouble that's
because the grassroots does not trust
him and they don't trust him for a very
good reason after four years of a
populist uprising against big government
Mitt Romney is running to the left of
Barack Obama on Medicare he has no
credible plans to cut government he's a
flip-flopping northeastern moderate at a
time when people are looking for more
radical solutions rampal is an a solid
and stunning second place consider this
while Mitt Romney was getting basically
the same vote in Iowa and increasing his
total from 2008 in New Hampshire by just
five percentage points rampal more than
doubled his total in Iowa and tripled
his total in New Hampshire he now has
more than twice the number of total
votes then Newt Gingrich does he got
more votes last night the newt gingrich
Rick Santorum and Rick Perry combined
why because his message resonates now
more than it did four years ago because
we have seen the predictions that he
made come true we had a bubble we had
mal investments we've had all kinds of
government interventions that have put
us on the precipice of fiscal
catastrophe that's why Ron Paul is
trending and making the entire
Republican establishment very nervous
and number three this race is too weird
to call we've already chewed up and spit
out six different frontrunners in this
national campaign whether they were
declared or not from Donald Trump to
Herman Cain to Newt Gingrich who was
ahead in the polls less than a month ago
these are fluid times in national
politics Republican politics in
particular there's a civil
wore a foot deciding what is going to be
the future of this party is it going to
be big government conservatism all
foreign policy intervention all the time
or is it going to harken back to a more
limited and modest role for the federal
government in the likes of Barry
Goldwater and so on Ron Paul is the only
other candidate out there right now who
has a nationwide campaign and a plan to
be there at the finish line so looking
forward are we going to see a two-man
race with clear-cut ideas about two
different philosophies of governance
here's hoping so for recent TV I'm Matt
Welch
you